bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons ensemble le sommaire de cette
émission
spécialiste des mondes anciens notre
invités nous présente dans quelques
instants ces découvertes preuves de
l'existence de créatures légendaires
Shetland une adaptation 2.0 de Roméo et
Juliette écrite avec des jeunes et
interprétés par des jeunes cinquantinois
est à découvrir ce soir à la ferme de
Bel et bas à Guyancourt les 15 et 16 mai
le prisme à Élancourt présente perdu
dans Stockholm une comédie poétique de
tant de crise Nicolas Gervais a
rencontré Pierre note auteur et metteur
en scène
après plusieurs années de recherches
dans le désert du
taclam à Cannes pardon situé à l'ouest
de la Chine notre invité archéologue
voyageur naturalistes à découvert
l'existence d'une créature légendaire un
étrange squelette qui aurait sa place au
Musée d'histoire naturelle à Paris mais
qui nous est présenté en exclusivité à
la Commanderie des Templiers à Élancourt
jusqu'au 6 juillet bonsoir Jamel zedom
bonsoir alors vous connais sous le nom
de Monsieur Z et pour entrer tout de
suite dans le vif du sujet alors quel
est ce vestige qu'avez-vous trouvé et
bien j'ai eu la grande chance de trouver
dans ce désert un squelette tout à fait
étrange un squelette complet d'un animal
non encore identifié à ce jour et qui
correspond à un mythe une légende locale
du takamakan qui s'appelle la tortue des
cannes donc c'est un squelette avec une
anatomie tout à fait particulière tout à
fait étrange vous pouvez nous la décrire
alors et c'est un animal qui est doté
d'une carapace pointue assez lourde de
membres antérieurs très très massif et
puis d'une tête avec trois paires dieux
donc six yeux voilà 6 orbites
oculaires et puis des membres à vente
très très rigides un peu comme des
défenses donc c'est une anatomie tout à
fait étonnante et il se trouve que ça
correspond à une légende ancienne qui
est une légende chinoise absolument
alors c'est la légende qui a été qui a
fleuri dans cette région et qui prétend
que un moine a trouvé une tortue à ses
yeux et que cette cette animal curieux
avait la capacité de voir les trois
temps de la ville le passé le présent et
le futur et dans l'imaginaire bouddhiste
celui qui voit les trois temps de la vie
et délivré de la peur de mourir donc il
aurait dû il y a toute une histoire il
aurait dû rendre cette tortue à
l'empereur comme il aime et puis bon il
l'a gardé pour lui-même et donc c'en est
suivi un conflit des guerres etc donc
toute une mythologie et
de croiser le regard ces trois regards
finalement on a le don de guérison
moi je me borne à collecter des
informations à trouver des pièges que je
présente mais effectivement il y a toute
une toute un rituel qui fait là-dessus
avec des danses des masques etc et oui
je pense qu'il y a des gens qui ont un
moment ont cru vraiment que
cette créature avait des pouvoirs
extraordinaires alors là en fait vous
êtes en train de nous dire finalement
par ces traces vous vous démontrez la
l'existence d'une nouvelle théorie de
nouvelles formes animales du nouvel
histoire naturelle donc ça voudrait dire
quoi la clé les les animaux légendaires
pourraient exister absolument alors
absolument derrière les légendes il se
peut qu'il y ait des vrais réalité
quand on s'intéresse à un certain nombre
de champ de recherche on peut trouver
des éléments qui nous incitent à penser
il se trouve que moi pendant longtemps
j'étais le seul à le croire et je suis
de moins en moins seul que je présente
cette exposition avec des éléments
d'épreuve des pièces d'archéologie des
textes des gravures des squelettes et
tout porte à croire que oui dans
certains cas on peut on peut imaginer
que ces créatures fabuleuses ont bien
une réalité
et qu'on est passé à côté on ne sait pas
tous on ne sait pas on ne connaît pas
toute l'histoire de la Terre en fait
vous êtes un archéologue de l'imaginaire
c'est comme ça qu'on peut vous qualifier
alors vous avez créé votre propre
bestiaire vous présenter donc voilà
cette exposition à la Commanderie des
Templiers qui
s'articule autour de 4 univers dont
celui de la tortue des cannes il y en a
donc trois autres à découvrir
allez qu'est-ce qui vous plaît
finalement là dans le vrai faux univers
historique c'est vraiment ça c'est le
jeu du vrai faux c'est à dire c'est
c'est un jeu qui relève de l'enfance
l'époque où on se dit et si c'était vrai
et bien c'est ça ça part de ça du
plaisir sur les artistes sont des
enfants qui ont pas grandi qui
continuent à l'être en tout cas enfants
et oui vous m'avez démasqué donc oui je
m'amuse à être une sorte de
d'archéologues de l'imaginaire et ça
m'amuse et
j'ose croire que les visiteurs s'amusent
aussi avec moi en tout cas je sais que
j'ai croisé
deux types de remarques d'abord vous
vous avez fait rêver vous avez pendant
deux heures de 1h30 2h parce que ça il y
a beaucoup de choses à lire et à voir
les gens se rentrent dans l'histoire
et
il me salue à la fin d'expo me disant
vous m'avez j'ai une parenthèse pour une
part pendant deux heures j'étais pas là
j'étais ailleurs vous avez fait rêver et
puis il y a d'autres qui sortent avec un
sourire on peut narquois une souris en
sortant
de raconter des histoires
entre le vrai et le faux alors justement
premier déjà premièrement comment vous
est venu l'idée de créer des des
créatures comme ça étranges légendaires
pourquoi les animaux alors créer des
créatures comme ça des formes animales
et ben je parlais de l'enfance mes
premiers souvenirs c'est ça c'est
l'enfance c'est gamin je m'amusais à
faire ça avec du papier d'emballage des
bonbons voilà c'est une c'est vrai ça et
je m'en suis souvenu il y a pas très
longtemps et ça m'est revenu comme une
comme un vent du passé si vous voulez et
je me suis vu gamin pendant les récré en
au lieu de jouer au foot je sais pas
jouer au foot j'ai le droit et de faire
des animaux avec des bouts de papier et
ça m'a pas quitté en réalité je m'amuse
à voilà et donc je comment je travaille
cette simple je commence par
trouver des formes voilà parce qu'en
fait votre démarche elle est à la fois
artistique ethnologique scientifique
vous disiez dans le cadre de
l'exposition va trouver des des éléments
écrits des dessins des alors voilà
comment comment vous travaillez
exactement alors d'abord je cherche et
je trouve des formes moi ce qui
m'intéresse le sculpteur là donc c'est
la forme qui m'intéressait la forme qui
me plaît et puis comme je m'intéresse
beaucoup au monde animal la forme
animale elle impose une certaine forme
d'anatomie enfin comme en même temps que
je la fais j'imagine bouger vivre etc et
puis une fois que la forme est trouvée
à ce moment là je commence à la mettre
vers le dans une réalité donc je vais la
placer dans un environnement une
histoire dans une culture et j'ai j'aime
l'histoire naturelle je vous l'ai dit
mais j'aime aussi les arts premiers
j'aime beaucoup les arts premiers je
m'intéresse beaucoup à ça et c'est une
forme d'art qui me touche
particulièrement et donc je vais en même
temps faire des recherches documentaires
dans une culture par exemple la culture
Papou la culture de nouvelle aujourd'hui
par exemple pour reprendre la tortue des
cannes vous allez resituer complètement
le contexte et géographie technologique
scientifique
la tortue en elle-même par exemple son
corps la façon dont il est articulée
vous vous êtes servis de modèle et
débutant non c'est la forme moi je
m'amuse à trouver des formes une forme
qui m'amuse en fait une fois qu'elle est
qu'elle tient qu'elle me satisfait après
je vais la placer dans un univers dans
un vrai univers dans un vrai contexte et
je vais
peut-être passer
si on est plusieurs à croire que tout ça
est vrai je pense que ça pourra devenir
vrai
je m'amuse jusqu'au bout je pense que le
jeu c'est d'aller jusqu'au bout de son
rêve et en tout cas c'est le mien donc
je vous laisse juge tous les éléments
sont présentés donc le mieux c'est de se
rendre à l'exposition donc qui a lieu
jusqu'au 6 juillet la commanderie des
Templiers à Élancourt c'est du mercredi
au dimanche 14h 18h toutes les
informations pour trouver
l'essentiel donc des indications pour
s'y rendre évidemment merci beaucoup
Monsieur Z moi qui vous remercie
maintenant nous allons nous rendre nous
du côté de Guyancourt ou ce soir se
tient la dernière représentation de
Shetland donc une version adaptée Roméo
et Juliette 2.0 des images de Jonathan
Wilman
ni sous 7.8 et molokoste de pseudonymes
derrière lesquels se cachent deux
adolescents en quête d'amour à travers
leurs écrans ils tchat seront contre
virtuellement se découvre sur la toile
mais pour combien de temps et que se
passera-t-il une fois dans la vraie vie
c'est une histoire d'amour qui va mal
tourner entre deux adolescents parce
qu'il y a des relais qui sont pas des
relais humains mais des relais justement
technologiques qui qui crée des rumeurs
et des et des choses fausses sur ces
deux adolescents et qui les emprisonnent
dans un endroit dont ils ne peuvent plus
sortir c'est ces outils qui sont à la
fois géniaux parce que très rapide et
qui permettent une plus grande
connaissance du monde et de l'autre et
en même temps qu'il la freine dans une
dans une réalité écrit par Dominique
sans Pierrot et mis en scène par Aurélie
van dendael Chatland et la restitution
d'une création théâtrale écrite avec des
jeunes et interprétés par des jeunes 50
chinois une à la frontière du réel dans
laquelle la mise en scène relève le défi
d'incorporer les nouvelles technologies
tout en conservant la théâtralité et le
jeu des comédiens pour moi c'est très
important de parler de des nouvelles
technologies au théâtre qu'est-ce qu'on
peut en faire comment on peut les
exploiter et c'était l'enjeu du projet
puisque c'est de parler de des dérives
des réseaux sociaux et de
l'incommunicabilité à travers les
nouveaux médias la mise en scène c'est
une alternance de séquences entre ces
moments très intimes que nous on a
choisi de poser dans des vestiaires qui
sont un petit peu pour nous la chambre
adolescente et un univers de gymnase
très collectif très public dans lequel
on doit se donner à voir autant en sport
donc autant le corps que que le groupe
en fait et comment on est face au groupe
Shetland une adaptation 2.0 de Roméo et
Juliette est à découvrir gratuitement
les 29 et 30 avril à la ferme de Bel et
bas à Guyancourt
perdu dans Stockholm une comédie
poétique de tant de crise à découvrir
les 15 et 16 mai au prisme à Élancourt
Nicolas Gervais a rencontré Pierre note
l'auteur et le metteur en scène
artiste résidence au prismaël en cours
et au Théâtre du Rond-Point à Paris il
met en scène des pièces toujours drôles
et décalées impeccablement écrite et
mise en scène il revient cette année
avec une nouvelle création intitulée
perdue dans stockage voici pierre note
dans le kiosque et toi tu suis
il nous regarde
elle est là en partie mais elle est là
le président de région
après
Circus sortir de sa mère on va présenter
là le 15 et 16 mai au prisme perdu dans
cette Colm avec Juliette Colomb
priscillarais Sylvie Laguna que j'ai
écrit et que je mets en scène et qu'on
répète en ce moment pour la dernière
fois aujourd'hui dans la petite salle du
prisme
qui se trouve dans les hauteurs d'une
ville de bord de mer comme Trouville par
exemple un mobil-home témoin parce que
c'est la crise du logement et que la
tante ne sait pas du tout où aller elle
vit avec un jeune homme totalement perdu
pas tout à fait à l'aise dans ses
baskets qui se travestit en femme et qui
veut changer de sexe c'est son projet
dans la vie et il a kidnappé une
comédienne en pensant qu'elle était
peut-être
la présidente d'honneur du festival du
film américain de ville c'est-à-dire une
star et il se rend compte que pas du
tout elle n'a rien à voir avec ça elle
est complètement inconnue c'est une
pièce de crise avec une crise de
logement une crise identité une crise
professionnelle et ces trois petites
bonnes femmes vont essayer de
trouver les moyens de sortir de leur
crise et ensemble de vivre une aventure
un peu un peu un peu un peu différente
un peu palpitante qu'il est sortira
chacune une aventure qui ne sortira
chacune de leurs de leurs crises et de
leur désastreets de leur désarroi
large et on prend les voiles demain je
rachète le complexe des mobil-home
témoin et je bâti mon école tout va bien
on a affaire à des individus à des
figures qui sont inaccues qui sont dans
des états de désarroi de des astres ils
sont perdus un peu dans la vie parce que
voilà c'est ça qui me troublent qui
m'intéresse qui me touche ça nous
regarde tous évidemment ils sont dans
ces états-là et puis ils vont chacun
chacune la ce sont trois femmes dont tu
n'es pas mal ils vont chacune mais elles
vont chacune essayer de sortir de leur
désastre de leur naufrage et et tenter
de s'accomplir ensemble et c'est
ensemble qu'elles vont y parvenir c'est
toujours un peu ça moi que je crois mes
pièces racontent d'une manière ou d'une
autre soit dans le cadre de la famille
dans le cadre des relations amoureuses
là c'est dans le cadre de de de
vie particulièrement chahuter par des
crises financières
identitaires professionnelles sociales
de tous ordres qu'on connaît tous
particulièrement en ce moment
ah les vaches quoi les vaches normandes
elles ont tous sifflé les [__]
elles ont tous siroté whisky vodka
liqueur de poires j'avais tout planqué
dans l'armoire à kimono je ne retrouve
plus rien nos petites élèves ont
découvertes mais cachettes elles se sont
toutes enfiler nos bouteilles les pièces
elles proposent simplement d'essayer de
dresser des portraits joyeux d'individus
qui nous ressemblent et pour essayer
d'en rire un peu et puis pour essayer de
de réfléchir à une manière peut-être
plus poétique décaler un peu inventive
un peu joyeuse de s'en sortir l'espace
d'une représentation
on le voit tu parles elles ont tout vu
sans tes bonheur ça passe par le rythme
pour moi il est important que ce soit
toujours très vivant très vivant très
rythmé très enlevé on essaie de
d'organiser un mouvement de fête pour
que tout le monde participe à un moment
donné à un moment de réconciliation
la saison prochaine je nous mets en
scène toutes les trois dans les trois
sœurs de Tchekhov en version kabuki et
on tourne la pièce dans toute la
Normandie
différentes
elles sont différentes parce qu'elles
font partie de l'action peut-être les
comédiens jouent une scène particulière
et puis un moment donné il la joue en
chanson de mêler la chanson de mêler la
danse de mêler la poésie de mêler la
grossièreté de mêler les conneries mais
j'aime beaucoup les conneries les
petites conneries on fait des crêpes par
exemple et on va les manger ensuite on
les partagera peut-être c'est des petits
moments comme ça qui me semblent des
moments de séduction qu'on partage avec
le public j'aperçois
des gens
se dessine
là-bas la côte anglaise et nous voilà
sauver les autres
si tu pédalo si seul serait d’eau je
vois des planches des parasols des
cerfs-volants qui tournera dans un ciel
dégage
et après s'être perdu dans cette école
me retrouvons Aurélia qui n'était pas
bien loin puisqu'elle était sur le
plateau de TV fils
comme nous sommes mercredi c'est l'heure
de notre chronique cinéphile et cette
semaine notre professionnelle du cinéma
et Gaël Pinault responsable du grenier à
sel à Trappes sans coup de cœur
au cinéma Le Grenier à celle de Trappes
nous vous proposons une soirée
complètement déjantée avec deux films de
Quentin Dupieux le premier c'est Reber
qui est un film hallucinant d'un pneu
serial killer qui ça se passe dans le
désert californien un vrai film donc
déjanté comme le titre de la soirée
et le deuxième film c'est Wang cops et
là on est dans le quotidien d'une de
Juke un flic corrompu à Los Angeles et
de toute son équipe et tout le
commissariat c'est un petit peu
n'importe quoi
ils vend du vent de la drogue caché dans
des rats ils font des tas de magouilles
et ce sont deux films qui sont un petit
peu un petit peu fou comme on aime
beaucoup et que nous vous proposons donc
le mercredi 7 mai à partir de 19h le
tarif c'est les tarifs du cinéma
et vous retrouver tout ça sur notre site
internet cinéma grenier à sel point
comme
allez maintenant place à l'agenda je
vous propose deux idées de sortie ces
prochains jours alors tout d'abord vous
pouvez assister aux deux tournois de
qualification de la 15e édition du
championnat intercollège de match
d'improvisation théâtrale de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines rien que ça et
ce sera donc vendredi 2 mai au prisme à
en cours vous pouvez également vous
rendre à la salle des archives
municipales à Versailles qui accueille
vendredi et samedi de 14h à 18h une
exposition autour du face entier
anniversaire de la guerre de la fin de
la guerre d'Indochine voilà notre
émission est à présent terminée merci de
nous avoir suivi je vous retrouve donc
la semaine prochaine en direct à 18h30 à
mercredi